un beau 17 degrés dans l'air et les
jardins et potagers s'anime l'envi de
désherber de semer de préparer les
prochaines récoltes accompagne la
douceur de cette fin d'hiver
comment s'organisent les potagers
reportage du côté des jardins familiaux
de la métropole de tours aurélie renault
près du quartier des deux lions philippe
et michel s'activent depuis quelques
jours sur leur jardin familial
la terre est prête à accueillir les
premiers semis mais attention pas
question de se précipiter
doit-on ne faut pas de passer de façon
jardin gerlac y planter des tomates
maintenant il va avoir des surprises et
tomates pendant le 15 mai lyonnais
qu'est-ce qu'on peut planter en ce
moment là les patates et puis les pipots
un peu plus loin cette fois nous sommes
plein de la gloriette florentin et
corentin profitent de leurs vacances
pour nettoyer leur jardin qu'ils ont
acquis il y a deux ans hier on a fait
tous les semis déjà à l'appartement pour
pour ensuite pouvoir planter à partir de
mai et puis on va peut-être revenir un
peu dans la semaine aussi pour continuer
un peu enlevée l'herbe ou autre il fait
super beau il fait bon donc on est bien
il fait frais le matin en plus que c'est
agréable
le printemps n'est vraiment pas loin
résultat les jardiniers s'autorise à
planter quelques dahlias et eris ainsi
que plusieurs plantes aromatiques
on a taillé tout ce qui avait un peu
séché même les lavandes pour cars
partent bien au printemps et puis on a
fait des boutures des boutures de
plantes plantes de curry et du temps
pour voir si ça repart
et comme tous les jardiniers corentin et
florentins ont le nez sur le calendrier
il faudra attendre le 13 mai après les
saints de glace pour planter au potager